the four on our team is already hard at
work developing new heroes and content
that will be released during each new
season of the war between the factions
the faction war is really the in-game
illustration of the neverending war
between the Knights the samurai and the
Vikings it really acts as the
cornerstone of our post-launch schedule
every free month we have a new season of
the faction war and it will be the
opportunity to introduce new content
each season we'll add two unique heroes
with a dedicated set of weapons and play
styles plus free for all players each
season will expand the world with two
new maps to fight for control of
we will continue to enrich an add
additional content to the game through
the air code from day one every hero
will be able to advance through
reputation level unlocking new ways to
customize the play style and look of
your warrior free updates will expand
the progression of each with new tiers
new weapons new armor and more
increasing the number of competitive
builds for all heroes free updates will
also add new features and gameplay modes
beginning with tournaments and ranked
mode coming later this year
with the season pass get to unique
heroes released at each season with one
week early access plus exclusive
benefits content and more for honor is
there for the long term we are very very
excited to share with you everything we
have planned moving forward the war
starts February 14th and it is just the
beginning
you